if you've taken a menthol cough drop you
probably noticed a minty flavor and a
cool numbing sensation in the back of
your throat that feeling is similar to
the one you get from smoking bees
menthol cigarettes and it's part of why
the binding administration is trying to
prevent them from being sold health
officials say that mental cigarettes are
more appealing to young people because
the menthol eases the throat irritation
that you experience when you first try a
cigarette aside from regular tobacco
menthols are currently the only flavor
of cigarette allowed on the market
and they're popular 43 of smokers in the
us used menthols in 2020. here's why the
fda wants to ban them from being sold
and distributed in the u.s and why the
move is being opposed by some black
community leaders menthol a compound
that occurs naturally in mint plants
triggers the same receptors we use to
sense cold which creates that numb
chilling sensation
menthol brands like newport the most
popular menthol in the us emphasize the
flavor in their older marketing
[Music]
cigarettes but the fda says that in
addition to reducing the harshness of
smoking menthol also makes it harder to
quit menthol interacts with nicotine in
the brain to enhance nicotine's
addictive effects according to the fda
making menthol cigarettes even more
addictive than regular cigarettes so
they start kids younger and then they
keep them hooked for our lifetime us
officials say the biggest u.s tobacco
companies have rejected the fda's
findings they say that mental cigarettes
don't have any different health effect
than a regular cigarette despite this
the fda got white house support to move
forward on the ban last year as part of
the biden administration's cancer
moonshot initiative which aims to reduce
the cancer death rate by at least 50
percent over the next 25 years
the rules announced today would enforce
regulations related to what stores sell
and what companies manufacture and
distribute
a recent study projected that a ban on
menthol cigarettes would prompt an
estimated 1.3 million u.s smokers to
quit the fda says that menthol smoking
disproportionately impacts youth and
young adults
in 2019 researchers estimated that more
than 1 million u.s middle and high
school students had smoked a cigarette
in the last month
of those about 47 percent reported
smoking a menthol
the flavor is also popular among black
smokers
for decades cigarette companies have
marketed mental brands like newport cool
and salem to black people distributing
free packs in black neighborhoods and
running magazine and billboard ads
depicting carefree black smokers black
smokers are more likely to use menthols
they also die at higher rates of
smoking-related cancers than other
groups according to the cdc
and u.s health officials say the ban
would help address those disparities the
naacp has been in support of the ban
saying that the targeting and marketing
of menthol flavoring by the tobacco
industry have had a devastating impact
on our community but others think the
ban could present problems reynolds
american which makes newport has given
money to prominent black community
leaders who have opposed the ban like
reverend al sharpton and civil rights
attorney ben crump krump says he's
accepted money from reynolds for things
like scholarships for black youth but
the money has not influenced his opinion
sharpton did not reply to request for
comment they and groups like the aclu
and members of the congressional black
caucus have expressed concerns that the
ban will disproportionately impact
people of color they have argued that
menthol bans would lead to racial
profiling by police and expand the
illicit market for cigarettes in a
statement to the wall street journal
reynolds said it's important to note
that we do not make contributions
conditional upon organizations
maintaining a particular position the
biden administration has said that
enforcement of a ban would target
manufacturers and sellers this is not
about going after individuals smoking
menthol cigarettes this is about
manufacturers and people who are selling
them tobacco companies could lose
significant profits if the ban is
enforced they already have been
grappling with declining smoking rates
in the u.s and they are racing to
develop and market
alternative products like e-cigarettes
nicotine pouches lozenges
and other alternatives
in the hopes that smokers will switch
over to those even as smoking declines
menthols remain a huge part of the
cigarette market they account for about
a third of all cigarettes sold in the
u.s
british american tobacco which makes
reynolds american and altria which makes
marlboro are the top menthol makers in
the u.s menthol makes up roughly 30 of
british american tobacco's global
profits
altria said in a statement that it
believes harm reduction not prohibition
is the better path forward
reynolds and altria have hinted that
they may sue if the ban goes into effect
litigation could tie this up for years
so even if the fda moved forward and set
um an effective date of you know let's
say 2024
once that
ban were implemented then the cigarette
companies would likely sue and hold it
up further the fda will hear public
comments on its proposed rules and will
take time to review before finalizing
the ban